I'm frequently asked how on earth do you
know where to dig well that is a great
question and it actually bears on some
of the tools and the methods that
archaeologists employ so I'm going to
talk about the concept of archeological
surveying that is the process of looking
for sites I'm also going to introduce
you to the various types of remote
sensing that are now used by
archaeologists now first of all let's
define what we mean by a site because
these come in all shapes and sizes
within their textbook in the beginning
Brian Fagan and Nadia Durrani define a
site simply as a place where traces of
past human activity can be found and
these are normally identified by the
presence of artifacts some of them are
pretty obvious for example when you look
at the Athenian Acropolis
or a huge mound like Megiddo in Israel
you know that you're looking at an
ancient site but others can be very tiny
and almost indiscernible a site can be
as small as a scatter of flakes where
somebody once made a stone tool or as
large as Machu Picchu in Peru the trick
is to find the ones that aren't so easy
to detect there are two basic ways to
find sites doing reconnaissance on the
ground and doing it from the air or even
from space these days ground surveys
first began to be popular in the 1960s
and 70s and then the gains speed in the
1980s in part that's because they're
usually a much cheaper alternative to
digging and they can cover a lot more
ground they also allow you to ask and to
answer different types of questions than
you can when you're digging a single
site so for instance you might want to
investigate how intensively a specific
area in Greece was occupied during the
Bronze Age did that settlement pattern
change during the following Dark Ages
and what happened when things began to
return to normal and we get into the
eras of archaic and then classical
Greece
what happened in the region when the
Romans arrived what was it like in the
Byzantine period and how about the
Ottoman period or the modern period
ground surveys can help you answer these
kinds of questions by doing surveys and
identifying the various sites from
different periods in the area you can
actually construct a history of the
region without ever digging at a single
site many surveys though do lead into an
excavation afterward as the
archaeologists zoom in on one or more of
the most promising new sites that
they've just found and get a permit to
dig there these days though instead of
leading with a ground survey it actually
makes more sense to start with aerial
surveys if you can afford them this can
be as simple as buying aerial
photographs or satellite images from
specific companies or as complicated and
expensive as arranging for overhead
flights using lidar to survey your area
now we'll remember well we will return
to lidar in a moment but if you want to
buy imagery which is by far the easiest
way to go you do have some options one
option is to purchase declassified
military satellite images like the ones
taken by the corona program Corona was a
surveillance operation that was
conducted by US intelligence agencies
from 1960 to about 1972 images from the
program were Declassified by an
executive order in 1995 and they're now
used for all sorts of things including
finding archaeological sites if you
don't want to work with old black and
white photos you now also have the
option of getting up-to-the-minute
high-resolution color satellite images
from companies like digital globe there
are also images that have been taken
from the Space Shuttle for example
there's a fairly well known picture of
the city of Angkor in Cambodia that was
taken from the shuttle in which you can
see all of the buildings very clearly